stop making content for likes and views  and start making content for your  [ __ ] soul do you know how many people  continue to put out content of their  body because that's where they get the  likes and they have no interest in doing  that anymore but they keep doing it  because they're [ __ ] stuck in the  jail of the [ __ ] algorithm get the  [ __ ] out of the algorithm get the [ __ ]  out of the algorithm do you know what  happened  if i listened to that do you understand  how big of a wine presence i had in 2010  i became the guy do you understand what  happened when i first started making  business and mindset strategy content  every comment was stay in your lane wine  guy what do you know about business i'm  like i know a lot actually  stop making content for likes and views  and math and start making content for  your [ __ ]  [Music]